good morning believe nation today's
messages always be at your best over to
you Floyd Mayweather jealousy people
jealous are you
cosmos success so anytime you successful
Hitomi jealousy and people won't be when
they're already won't like you some time
with you and Claire servantis somebody
won't like you when you're in school
right but I don't stop you from going
right and you still go to and be your
best all right
so same thing like my job I still go
into being be at my best if you want
opportunities to come to you they need
to always be at your best when I'm
making these videos when I'm writing my
newsletter when I'm on my radio show
when I'm creating my book I imagine that
one of my mentors is gonna be reading it
I'm matching that Tony Robbins is gonna
be watching it I imagine that I already
have a million subscribers
I imagine that somebody who can make a
life-changing impact on me is gonna be
listening gonna be watching gonna be
reading because one day they will be and
if I'm not at my best if I'm not
producing at that level then when they
do come they won't be impressed so if
you want those opportunities to come to
you then you need to always be at your
best believe so my question that a few
guys today is I want to know what you do
to make sure that you are always at your
best what habits you have what routines
you have what you tell yourself let me
know leaving the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of vinspresso
more expresso keep me going